[Music]
I want you to think of something that could be
improved in the sexual field, say if
you can't talk,
your [ __ ]
aren't very good
and it seemed to me
that what happens to you is absolutely normal
in a couple that has been
using tobacco for as long as you have  there are hidden rows desires
that we ignore
reaches orgasm in intercourse as a weapon
and I would recommend that you investigate it is in
your own sexuality
[Music]
how
you are laughing at me is everything fine
really no it is not fine that you continue I
am getting married I am very comfortable  I am very comfortable right
now
but believe me if there is wood if there is a wick
if there is desire everything can come back in
February
and well
[Music]
[Applause]
well
he
and then set on fire
[Music]
Madrid seems very modern
but Madrid does not move anything